now I hope you're starting to see where
this is going to go right I can do as
many trapeziums as I like I'm gonna do
one more okay here we go and this time
what we're gonna do is instead of
picking a specific number like one
trapezium or two trapeziums I'm going to
imagine dicing this up into some like
whatever number of trapeziums you like
so in this case I don't know how many of
our drawing I've gone 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8
trapeziums okay but you could draw 9 or
15 or whatever you want okay how are we
going to work out this same thing well
look at it carefully right I've got look
closely I've got a beginning value and
an end value okay
it sits over here this is what I would
have called y1 and this is what I would
have called Y whatever whatever I get up
to okay now I'm going to do something a
little bit strange you know how we've
been counting here and saying y1 y2 and
then y1 y2 y3 and for reasons that you
become clear in a moment I'm going to
shift instead of starting from one I'm
gonna start from zero okay I know that
seems weird but trust me well it will
come clear in about five minutes okay so
let's call this guy y0 what will the
next one be it'll be y1 the next one
will be y2 this want to be y 3 y 4 5 6 7
the last one is going to be Y 8
now the reason why I'm starting at 0 is
because remember I counted for you the
number of trapeziums here there's a
trapeziums
now the last value for y the last
function value it'll be y 8 it'll match
the same number of trapeziums
that I've got so now let's go ahead and
write down the trapezoidal rule for this
with whatever number of our trapeziums
that I got the area is going to be
approximately equal to now have a look
I've got an H on to right that's the
same thing I get at the front of every
single one but how do I work out H in
this case here's H here's H again here's
H as a whole bunch of H's right well
last time what we did was we said okay
work out the top take away the bottom
and then we divide by two because we had
two trapeziums well this time I'm not
going to divide by two
I'm going to divide by it well in this
case I divide by H right because I can
see one two three four five six seven
eight H's okay so to work out my H
that's the way I'm going to do it the H
will be let's write it up here this H
will be equal to the top boundary take
away the bottom and then we're going to
divide by however many trapeziums I've
got in this drawing I've done eight
because I can't do infinite I'd be
drawing forever but I can just call that
number whatever number of trapeziums I
would like so I'm going to call it n
where n is the number of trapeziums okay
so that's how we work out the height of
each trapezium right good and now I
start doing the rest of it which is the
parallel sides right now the first
trapezium will be whoops it'll be Y
naught plus y1 there's the first
trapezium the second shrimpie zoom will
be y1 plus y to the third trapezium will
be y2 plus y3 you're probably starting
to get sick of this right you like to
how many of these do I have to write
before I can end right y3 plus y4 I'm
just trying to establish a pattern for
hit you here right eventually I'm going
to add up and the final one will look
like this H on two now what will its
y-values be well in this case it'd be y7
+ y 8 yeah but I'm trying to do it for
any number of trapeziums so it's the
last one and the second last one which
would be Y n minus 1 and Y and okay
which in this case is y7 + y 8 so to
remind you Abby
good question what is B take away a it's
going to be I'll write it in blue so it
matches it's going to be our top
boundary B take away our bottom boundary
that's how we got this distance here be
take away a do you remember when we did
the very first example we did three take
away one right well this is going to be
B take away a so we're doing something
called generalization this is for any
value of a any value of B yes-mo a it
does look a bit like statistics we will
come to that later as mrs. lasers just
said okay now have a look at this I know
this looks like an enormous mess it is
so let's try and simplify it so we have
less that we need to actually keep in
our brains okay the first thing is I
hope you can see there's a ton of
factorization that you can do what is
the common factor that appears every
single time for every pair of brackets
what can I factorize out from all of
them you know and see it well done Eddie
is Sean perfect okay so H on to it
appears here then it appears again then
it appears again it appears every single
time for every single trapezium right
so therefore what I'm going to do is
it's got time to write H on to you know
whatever number of times I'm just going
to write at once and then factorize it
out from everything okay so I write
approximately equals H on to and now
open brackets and then I write
everything inside the brackets so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to write it
in a bit of an unusual way okay I'm
gonna write y1 and then I get the Y 1
from the first trapezium but then I get
the y 1 from the second trapezium do you
see that in fact let me just highlight
that to make it really clear I've got
the Y 1 from the first trapezium and the
Y 1 from the second trapezium so here
they are appearing down the bottom okay
but then as you move forward right you
get a whiter I'm going to write this
underneath partly because I need the
space but also so you can see the
pattern I get the Y to that happens
twice as well right have a look let's
pick another color here I've got the
white shoe from the second trapezium and
the y2 from the third trapezium so these
guys are also in a pair in fact every
one of these terms is going to be in a
pair y3 and y3
why 4 + y 4 and so on this is going to
keep on going until the very end there's
one last term on the end that doesn't
pair up which one is it
have a look yeah in this example why a
it's the very last one right I'm gonna
do it in general terms because I might
not actually have 8 and I have 7 or 15
or whatever so I'm gonna write it as Y
and this is the very last one and then I
end my brackets okay so what if I got
here I am going to write this by saying
I don't need to double up all of these
ones in between right I have my H over
two at the front I've got the very first
function value that's this guy here I
also have the very last function value
that's why N and then what I've got is
double of every function value in the
middle the Y ones twos threes fours
fives all the way up until the second
last one so therefore I'm gonna
factorize out the two and then I'm going
to write y1 plus y2 plus y3 however many
there are and then I'm done okay so what
have I got here this is the entire what
we call the trapezoidal rule and this is
the part that you need to remember to
make sure that you know what each ph
signifies this is your first function
value it's that vertical line there
sorry my writing is extra messy today
there's my second function value because
oh sorry second it's my last function
values what I should have said its
second in the order that I wrote it on
the line you know what I mean it's the
last function value there and then all
of these guys in here are the middle
function values and all of them are
doubled up because we use each of these
middle ones in more than one trapezium
okay
take a breath you just derived the
entire trapezoidal rule this is
how we can use trapeziums to get an
approximate sense of what the area is
now before we conclude okay and I let
you have a go at the exercises here what
you'll notice is here's my he's my
conclusion over here and what you'll
notice is that you like this is hard to
remember there's a lot to it right so
you can actually go to the reference
sheet and the trapezoidal rule is there
but I just want to give you a bit of a
caution because I don't really like the
way that the trapezoidal rule is written
on the reference sheet they've written
it that way for very deliberate reasons
so that it can stand alone but I think
the way that I've written it here is
much more succinct which is why I've
given it to you however I want to make
sure that you understand where the one
on the reference sheet comes from so if
you've got the reference sheet somewhere
nearby go ahead and pull it open here's
my reference sheet okay so if you're on
page perf a thank you mrs. Lee's trained
professional would have pointed that out
myself now you can see here in the
reference sheet page 1 some measurement
financial math page to your Etrigan your
stats page 3 which you've seen before I
hope you've been referring to it during
integral calculus is where you got all
your derivatives and integrals now right
down here in the bottom right hand
corner it's the final result on this
page it doesn't even tell you what it is
it's very unassuming but this is the
trapezoidal rule now I want you to
notice it is written differently to what
I've got right the start is in fact what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna let's see it
I'll grab a screenshot and let's bring
this guy over so I can write all over
the top of it sorry guys bear with me
get rid of that okay let's put these
side-by-side
Zoop all right all right and I can
actually and make it a bit smaller and
then I can make it bigger for you I
didn't make any sense alright let's have
a go so let's have a look how does this
thing start right well for starters
you're like wait a second what happened
to my H on to what is all this business
here B minus a on
to win where does that come from now the
observant among you will know where that
come from because we actually did this
earlier B - a what are they doing
they're trying to work out over here
what is the total height and then they
divided up into however many trapeziums
they've got so if you look back up the
top here
remember I said H is B minus a over N so
therefore it follows that H over 2 will
be B minus a on to em right B minus a on
to n this is the thing that appears at
the front of the reference sheet formula
okay there it is so that's just my H on
- I'm gonna write that as such with my
other green blue go through yeah
so that's H on to that part there okay
then they've got this F of a and F of B
what are those about okay what I've
written is directly above and I wonder
if you can see the parallel write this F
of a is just my first function value
I've written it as Y naught because it's
just a bit more succinct right f of B is
going to be my my last function value
over here because a is where you start B
is where you end
I've called that Y of M and you can see
they actually are using this sum this
and one all that language in there as
well okay and then lastly what's this
piece hanging out here on the end I
haven't used purple yet here okay so
it's just a bigger one another to say
forever - and then all of these guys in
here the Y 1 2 3 4 5 etc right there's
my two hanging out the front and then
here are all of these middle function
values just like you saw before and the
reason why the version on the reference
sheet is is sort of a little more
complicated is that you're using
function notation and what I'm trying to
do is make it a little more succinct for
you to write which is why I use wise
instead of F of this F of that etc okay
so what's a conclusion okay take a
breath we can approximate any interval
you like even the ones that you can't
integrate the ones that you can't find
the primitive function of you can
approximate them using the trapezoidal
rule
okay the integral will be approximately
equal to and then here's the way that
I've written the formula okay and this
has the first first the last last and
the middles in the middle but I wrote it
like this above so you can see the
parallel to the reference shape okay n
is the number of trapeziums that you've
got whether it's 1 or 2 or 8 or 8
million and the last thing I want to
mention is and this comes back to I
think it was max who said like are they
gonna specify like we want you to use
the trapezoidal rule and the answer is
yes and they'll be even more specific
than that like I said sometimes they
will say use the trapezoidal rule and
use it with exactly three trapeziums or
four trapeziums
they might say use one trapezium and
often the language that they all use
looks like this they'll say I'm using
four applications of the trapezoidal
rule which is to say put four trapeziums
on there well they might take three
applications of the trapezoidal rule
which is to say use three trapeziums
okay so well done we we had to work
really hard there because we derived a
result from scratch and I was a bit
cheeky if we had more time I probably
would have done one of these separately
so I hope it does make sense to you
we're using a simple shape a trapezium
came back at the top here to approximate
a complicated shape but if you have
enough simple shapes you can get very
very close to a complicated shape now if
they if they give you a question and
they want you to use the trapezoidal
rule I can guarantee that they will
specify the number of trapeziums they
want you to evaluate the only thing the
only reason why they wouldn't give you
the number of trapeziums if is if they
were trying to do this right maybe they
were trying to say can you tell me
whether the trapezoidal rule would
underestimate or overestimate your area
now if you have a look at these two
examples that we started here right you
don't need to know how many trapeziums
there are if you use one or two or eight
million you will always overestimate on
this right hand graph here because the
trapeziums will always be above the
graph and over here no matter how many
trapeziums you use one or two or a lot
you always underestimate the area in
order to work out like which one is
which there's a bit more language which
we're going to develop in future topic
so we will return to that when we do a
bit more calculus but that's the basic
idea to more directly answer your
question a B they will specify the
number of trapeziums they want if they
want you to use the trapezoidal rule